Oh
welcome back so before we go on to the
next talk which is
a string which has very interesting
title and we're I'm sure many of you
looking forward to it I would take this
opportunity to thank all the sponsors
for by data conference especially to do
continuum analytics who has been our
diamond sponsor and has essentially made
this event possible in addition to that
we all also like to thank blue yonder
clicks add square and all our other
sponsors who did make a big big effort
to make this conference happen so big
thanks to all of them so we have
redeemed and a Herick who's who's good
tell us how to write Python code and
make it run faster than the big names
out there and I will let him introduce
himself but okay so I would like to tell
him I would just like to tell that he
runs his own consulting firm and has
been working with a number of companies
before to show what to do with their
data or unto you thank you very much
hello everyone my name is redeem and
today I'll be talking about
optimizations now many of you may have
heard about deep learning which is bit
of a hype lately and Google actually can
you hear me like this I like to walk
around so maybe this is better
and Google published an algorithm called
word to vac which is a machine learning
method unsupervised machine learning
method after you train it it can answer
questions like Berlin is - Germany as
Paris is - and work to whack it doesn't
work
okay I'll try to contain myself but I
really like to walk around alright so
and the answer should be France or you
can ask it which of these words doesn't
fit dinner cereal and it should tell you
cereal and now the fascinating thing
about this is there is no manual input
you just give it a lot of text just
plain text sentences sequences of
characters basically no lists of
capitals no notion of what is food and
so on and the model automatically learns
these relationships just from plain text
that's the interesting thing now in
order to do this it needs a lot of data
and in the end the relationships are
captured by by vectors each each word is
a vector of numbers you can imagine it
as three hundred numbers so you take the
vector four King subtract the vector
form an add the vector for women and ask
what is the nearest actor to that and
interestingly word to bag will tell you
Queen which is what we would expect as
well but this talk is not actually about
about word to back itself of the math
behind it off that's interesting it's
more about the implementation because
Google they also released along with the
research paper that they released their
own implementation and now since this
has to be trained on really large
corpora you can imagine hundreds of
millions of sentences for it to perform
well it also needs to be super fast so
the implementation of Google is written
in C which is very tightly optimized
it's very nice even beautiful coding in
the way that is very compact and
optimized but it also fails on another
account which is it's supposed to be
used for research so people want to use
it extended maybe try some things
differently and it's not really possible
with that implementation that we have
from Google right there's all these
single letter variable names and and no
comments and I all mixed with all the
computations and so on so touching it is
really a challenge so what I did I
wanted to understand this model better
for my own purposes so I ported it to
Python so that's that's one thing I put
a nicer interface
say there was a lot of talk at this
conference at PI data and also Euro
Python about generators so hopefully you
know what that means so instead of
reading all the text from file as the
original did like one sentence per line
words in that sentence instead the
training comes from a generator each
sentence is a list of words as you can
see there at the top and it's really up
to you what the generator does it can
read the sentences from disk stream them
from disk one sentence at a time you can
read it from a zip disk or just compute
something on the fly it's up to you it
gives you much more flexibility and
connect it to that you can also plug
into all the other libraries and the
whole ecosystem of Python which is
amazing so for example if instead of
just using the words let's say you want
to limit eyes them okay all the
inflected work forms of a single word
you want to represent them by a single
token so you can use pattern or NLT kay
for that Python libraries or at the end
of that pipeline let's say we already
trained the word to that model and we
want to do something with these word
embeddings with the vectors maybe we can
improve our classification system you
know plug it in somehow continue the
pipeline the other way again python has
a lot of very interesting libraries
scikit-learn and so on we also heard a
lot about them at this conference so
that's pretty nice and a nice pythonic
interface instead of writing Python code
we can use that so that's all very nice
but how about performance the that's
that's one problem so of course it uses
vectors it uses matrices so naturally my
port used numpy which is like the
standard in the Python world for working
with that type of stuff and I wrote the
nine PI code to be fairly optimized so I
use the vector operations and sometimes
even nested loops could be expressed as
a single matrix operation so I try to
plug into the strength of numpy which is
using the internal compiled routines
rather than pure Python loops and I was
pretty happy with the result it was most
of the time this I would just call it a
day and use that but actually this numpy
optimized
numpy goal was still 20 times lower than
the C implementation which is not good
and we're not talking about millisecond
this is like a difference between
between training for a day and a
training for three weeks so the
difference is huge so I had to dig
deeper unluckily that meant translating
some of the nice Python stuff back into
C stuff but luckily this is a typical
HPC application which means there's a
tiny core of computation that takes a
lot of time and the rest doesn't matter
all that much about 20 lines of code
consumed 90% of the runtime so what I
did is I translated this tiny core into
psiphon which is one of the ways of
plugging into low-level routines and
after some profiling and debugging and
so on making sure we don't make any
temporary copies avoiding dynamical
locations by pre allocating arrays and
various other tricks I managed to match
the speed of the C implementation all
right so now we have a core code a port
that is pythonic and nice and little bit
of it is translated back into c
basically so that's a success but this
is Python so we can do better than C so
I continued optimizing now this may be
getting maybe a little bit obscure I
don't know how many of you know Blas
basically that's a blast tense for basic
linear algebra subroutines and you can
as an example imagine you have a vector
of numbers X you want to multiply each
each element of that vector by a scalar
and add the result into another vector
pretty primitive operation and if you
write that loop that you see on top and
see your compiler will generate pretty
reasonable code but the fact is Blas is
very highly optimized so if you use a
blast library to do the same thing it
will actually use very specific
instructions for you architecture and it
will take good care of cache processor
caches and translation lookaside buffer
and so on to really squeeze all the
performance from your hardware so what I
did was I translated that core routine
from
from loops from from see into using
these blasts the routines
it wasn't easy because from actually
numpy and sci-fi they already read blast
but we can't go from Seton to Python and
call something back that would kill the
performance so we have to directly call
these routines from C and after a bit of
digging I came up with what you see at
the bottom which works well and we can
do that and the result is three times
faster execution so before where the C
speed and now we are three times faster
which is which is pretty nice putting it
all together this is actually a
screenshot from the initial part since
then other people contributed more
optimizations and so on so putting all
the optimizations together which is the
bottom right number it's about a hundred
times faster now that the numpy baseline
yeah so the takeaway optimized numpy we
can still optimize it about two orders
of magnitude if we add if we are careful
about the memory and so on if you put
effort into it and I was also interested
in going the other direction because I'm
sure you've seen these benchmarks but
people right crappy algorithms crap
implementations and then they improve it
a million times so that was a bit sad
that I don't see that because I write
reasonable code from the start so I went
the other direction and I rewrote the
numpy baseline in pure Python just to
see how much we get from numpy itself
and the answer is another two orders of
magnitude okay so so from pure Python -
nice numpy one hundred times faster and
from nice numpy to thoroughly optimized
code another two and another 100 so
about 12,000 put together and I also
think this is an interesting benchmark
because on its own without needing
talking about deep learning or anything
like that
because people benchmark usually on
stuff that nobody cares about like
Fibonacci numbers yet it's that one of
the common benchmarks and actually we're
two vak is a self-contained simple
application which is what you want in
benchmark it has the high performance
requirements and so on at the same time
it's complex enough that people want to
use they even want to pay for it to have
it implement it and use it so it's
nobody will pay you for generating
Fibonacci numbers so this is an
interesting benchmark so this is just
one data point so we can't generalize
too much but if you never work with this
stuff before this is what you could
expect from from an application that
needs performance yeah here I prepared
some advanced infographics for you the
top image is how the original C
implementation works this light is about
parallelization so far everything I've
said was about single core running it
just in one one process one on one core
and the original implementation works on
a file which is in a fixed format it's
not flexible that's what I mentioned it
just splits this file into equal
segments into equal number of bytes and
each worker each thread process is its
segment now it's this part is not very
nicely coded I think this is the ugliest
part of the original C because when you
seek into the middle into some byte you
can be seeking into middle of a sentence
or middle of a word or even middle of a
character in case of multi byte
encodings and also from there it
processes a fixed number of words not
bytes but words so if there are short
words in its segment maybe it finishes
earlier and some part of the file is
never trained on or if the words are
long maybe it goes beyond the where the
other word starts and it trains multiple
times on the same it's a bit messy so
instead of the port which is the bottom
picture there is the sentences come from
a stream from the generator so there is
no sitting into the middle we just have
a sequence of sequence of sentences we
can go over so I put them into Cheung
them into jobs for performance reasons
and these jobs are put into a queue from
which each worker who lifts the job and
processes it fast quickly this is
possible because we're already working
on sea level so we can afford to release
the the Gil the global interpreter lock
services this is fast with threats
how does it work pretty well with a two
cores we get about one point 1.75 speed
up with 4 cores 2.85 this is a bit worse
than in the sea version where you get
1.9 and 3.2 respectively
it's because we're doing a bit more in
the Python we're doing some locking and
doing the job queuing and it has to be
thread safe and so on so there's a bit
more overhead and also interesting if
you look at the bottom at the top table
there's also a curious no accuracy you
can evaluate the model in terms of how
well it performs you have this set of
questions like Berlin is - Germany as
Frances and if the model gets it right
it's a success otherwise failure and you
can represent it by a single number at
the end and the port actually performs
better it gets better accuracy is
because we got rid of a lot of the
artifacts that were in the original
which are you are not really necessary
for the algorithm was just the way it
was implemented in NC and fix some other
stuff so it's it's much nicer more
extensible it's faster and it's also
qualitatively better so it's like a
triple win here so it's it's a nice in
my opinion port ok what didn't go so
well
scythe on has a thing called type memory
views for accessing arrays which is
supposed to be the way to do it I
couldn't get it to perform as well as
just plain pointers and I didn't see
much point so I spent some time on it
and in the end I just done memory
reviews and and wrote roll pointers
siphons dynamic compilation I didn't
want to make the poor dependent on
syphon because a lot of people
don't really use the training instead
they just download an already trained
model and they want to use the nice
pythonic interface to ask questions of
the model that's a perfectly valid use
case so when something goes wrong and
you can't compile it the cyclone version
I fall back to the numpy version and I
use dynamic compilation for that and I
thought I was very nice of cyclin to do
that but then one user reported a
problem with it and I asked on the site
on mailing list and they said that
actually you shouldn't do that it's a
horrible thing to do for some reasons
that I didn't really understand but that
was a big disappointment so you can't do
that in cipher
dynamic compilation plus now blessed was
the difference why we are actually
faster by the factor of three that I
talked about a bit earlier and I talked
to tomash who is the author of who was a
Googler and author of the original
implementation now his left Google is
moved on to the new Facebook AI lab but
of course he was he's well aware of
glass and when I asked him why why
didn't you use it why didn't you get
this extra boost and speed his reason
was very good very respectable and
that's because glass is a pain in the
ass it's it's difficult to to maintain
because you have to think about all
these rappers and it's this library the
superfast libraries come with their own
problems and Fortran and binary
interfaces and so on so he didn't want
to deal with that that was the reason
and now numpy and Syfy they shield us
from a lot of it but not all of it so
for example inside by if you multi point
spit on certain with certain blast
libraries such as the one that comes
with Apple computers it's called
accelerate if you multiply two vectors
in single precision you get the wrong
result when you do it through side by
because there's some incompatibility or
whatever so so there's a lot of it's a
bit annoying you get numpy shields you
from a lot of it inside pi but there's
still sometimes leaks through and it can
be nasty and then Python 3
the port is now lives as part of Jensen
which supports both Python 2 and Python
3 from the same codebase and keeping it
keeping all the optimizations working in
both pythons there was a or some minor
glitches but it's fixed it works now
nothing nothing too bad and that brings
me to the last slide first of all thanks
to Tomas Michael off for his original
implementation for doing the research
and all the really hard work and also to
Google for releasing it including
training it on the internal internal
data and releasing the model that was
very nice of people like me can just
play around with optimization which is
the easy part they did all the hard work
practical information the the port lives
engine seemed like a so you can find it
on github as I was porting it I was
writing a series of blog posts about
about how it went and how we didn't go
so if you want to read it in more detail
at your own pace that's the link at the
bottom and at the top is my contact
information like I was introduced I run
a small deaf and consulting company
where we specialized in machine learning
so if if you have a need of some
recommendation engine or content
filtering or ad targeting and so on you
can you can talk to me the contact is
there if you just want to discuss what
was done here that's the end thank
thank you for that nice and quick
overview there are any questions from
the audience
you I have a question regarding the
memory usage okay you basically for that
example you had like double the memory
and RAM talking about this table huh yes
well-spotted yeah the Python part takes
what is your question the question is is
this a linear growth as in like if I get
like enough data to have a half a gig
for sivak for the C version will I have
a one gig in usage or just specific
overhead it takes about double the
amount of memory constantly but yeah
that's what I want to say this the point
is that it's streaming there the
generators mean we just train on one
sentence and then we forget it we don't
like to load the entire 100 billion
words into memory at once so the memory
is constant no matter how large the
training corpuses you're using about
this is like again although it's a bit
less but let's say 500 megabytes of
memory good question
have you tried number because you
implemented the pure Python version
order you implemented a pure Python
version and what that is tours of
magnitude slower right then the best one
you got
have you tried number because sometimes
if it works you get two orders of
magnitude speed-up so have you tried it
yeah good question no I haven't I think
it's just adding one decorator to your
Python code in theory okay so maybe you
can try but this is interesting like I
talked here about that I think it's a
good benchmark because it's big enough
and at the same time compact enough so I
think this is actually a good direction
try different maybe number like you say
which I haven't tried but maybe there
are the tools that could be useful and
we can compare it on a realistic task so
let's I think that's it's a nice feature
of this hey write him and so I'm on the
point of number certainly number and
price ran might be interesting things
because as you say this is an
interesting real-world benchmark and
with your original C Python
implementation I guess a pi PI test as
well could be an interesting an
interesting way to lose a week and going
through the benchmarking possibilities
but every widgets good test and I'm
curious about the about your thoughts on
engineering performant code with Python
for deployment scenarios so one thing
that I on others when teaching things
like size then we talk about the best
way to get speed but not necessarily the
best way to make well engineered code
that's easy and robust for a team to
maintain you're a team of one two it's a
bit easier but you've made some really
fast solutions how do you deal with the
trade-off between Ultima speed and
maintainability so I didn't understand
the question fully oh sorry um you can
make some really really good
optimizations but it'll make the card
the code hard to maintain in the future
okay how do you make the trade-off
between maintainability and speed for
you know this and other I have yeah I
understand thank you that's a another
good point I already mention it a little
bit when I talked about blast
being pain in the ass that's exactly the
point where it starts getting tricky
when you have to maintain these various
connections to the various underlying
libraries that actually make you fast so
if you look at the the initial board was
pretty concise but if you look at the
the core function that was ported into
scythe on and optimized with Blas if you
look at it now inside Jensen
it's a pretty long piece of code with a
lot of nasty gotcha
fixes and branching so the trader if I
make there is as long as it depends on
how much performance we get because one
thing I didn't talk about here is the
the sigmoid table optimization and I
didn't really mention that and it's a
special optimization that was there in
the original C tool where you pre
compute some of the functions into
memory and that's something that was
very popular many many years ago because
your flowed CPU and instead you use Ram
but now we have such complex
architectures and the cache hierarchies
are so complex that I actually thought
this would be a regression I didn't want
to implement it but I did it was about 4
percent faster than without this
optimization so in my opinion this is
not really worth the code complexity so
if it was up to me I just write is up to
me but just ignore this optimization and
and go for maintainability without that
extra code and extra thinking about what
this does and how does it work so it's a
trade-off like you say hello that wasn't
a very interesting talk thank you you
mentioned this tool gets in magenta
magenta are you going to give it another
talk about that one or could you maybe
just in a few sentences explain where
that is sure so Jen zoom is a tool for a
large scale semantic modeling I'm the
author actually so that's why this is a
part of Jensen and it specifically uses
that pattern that we saw with with data
streaming a lot of machine learning
libraries text processing or otherwise
they load everything into
into like a large number array or
whatever and then work with that but in
NLP usually the corpora are very large
and you don't want to load everything
into RAM so Jen seem special
specifically targets that scenario where
the day dies large and you can just
stream through it and update the models
online and without without doing maybe
batch processing just go through the
stream and update models apart from
where to work you can find light and
semantic analysis and light and display
allocation and these types of algorithms
thank you hey welcome so on the subject
of maintainability another problem faced
by people working with with large
packages is going to be correctness of
the code and you've mentioned problems
with blasts and cross-platform
compatibility can you talk a little bit
about your test strategy unit tests
coverage your strategy of testing on
multiple operating systems just how
you're confident it'll work you mean
specifically forward to back here here
it was a bit it was a bit easier because
when usually when you implement
algorithms from academic papers you're
pretty much on your own if you ever done
it you know it's not an easy task
because that's just this formulas and
sometimes they're wrong and so on but
here it was easier because we had
already had a referential implementation
the sequel from Google from tomash so
one way of while developing it of
testing it was just by comparing if it
does what it shoot and like I said the
port is not one-to-one this is a
reemployment ation of the original ideas
not just translation of code but as long
as we're getting better accuracies we're
fine so that that's one way of testing
and then there's unit testing which is
maybe what you meant like seeing that we
don't break something and there are unit
testing in Python for this standard
stuff okay are there any further
questions okay if that's not
yes let's tango speaker once again
you